- So let's start with Diamond.
What's going on with you girl?
- Yes, well, Kelly, I'll be honest.
I've always been a super confident woman.
Like, I'm the life of the
party when I step into a room,
I am bringing so much positive energy.
I'm a mom,
I have my own business doing
social media management.
I host events.
And so with this year and
everything that's going on,
it literally stopped, as we all know,
and it totally knocked me off my square.
Everything paused, and I was really left
feeling lost and angry
and just really not knowing what to do.
I lost a lot of
connections with the people
and I really thrive off
that human connection.
Just tryna figure out how to
pivot my business in this time
where it's like so many
events and getting out there.
So I need to figure out
how do I get that confidence back, right?
Find that confident strong woman
that I know deep down inside that I am.
So I can really continue
to inspire my children,
my daughters.
And so I'm just tryna figure out like,
where do I even begin
with the year being so crazy and draining?
- I, well, maybe with
that meditation thing
he was just talking about,
but let's talk to Dr. Chopra.
- One thing you can do instinctly
anytime you're stressed
is use what I call the STOP formula.
S-T-O-P.
S stands for stop,
T stands for take three deep breaths
and smile from your head
to your toes, everywhere.
O, observe your breath and
your body, the sensations.
And then P, proceed with
awareness, compassion, and joy.
But what you're also doing,
which is very effective,
is you're expressing your vulnerability.
And that is very important.
It's a sign of strength
when we express our
vulnerabilities to each other,
we are stronger.
So we ask for help, and we give help.
Social scientists there days
talk about something called
the happiness formula,
which is basically,
are you seeing problems or
are you seeing opportunities?
What are the conditions of your living?
And do you have meaning and purpose?
And can you make other people happy?
The fastest way to increase
your self esteem and be happy
is to make somebody else happy.
- That, I, that's my favorite
thing that I've kind of
heard people say in this time,
'cause doing this show it's been
absolutely a blessing for me
personally because you hear,
you hear people say, "You know,
if you're having a hard time
why don't you help someone else?"
Not only does it just kinda take you away
from your own egocentric
moment that you're suffering,
but you're focusing on
someone else you're helping
and so and that makes you feel good.
And it's so true.
Do you ever, do you feel like that?
- Absolutely, I spend a
lot of my time doing that
to make myself feel better
when I can't just make myself feel better.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, I find that
if you're able to help someone bridge
that gap of trying to get
to that spot, whether it's,
you know, just to having a
conversation or being able to,
you know, help with this month's rent, or
it's something as small as
just being an ear to listen to.